à saint cyr l'école commune de 18 mille
cinq cents habitants de candidats de
s'opposent
sonia bros tête de liste de saint cyr au
coeur 2020 anciennement première
surveillante dans l'administration
pénitentiaire elle s'engage en politique
en 2008 sur la campagne électorale avec
le souhait de s'investir dans la ville
elle succède au mandat de bernard de
bain et devient maire en 2019
le programme il est à l'image de
l'équipe c'est à dire une regroupe les
besoins les envies de chaque quartier de
saint cyr et on va y trouver à
l'intérieur l'envi qu'on peut monter
voir monter aujourd'hui des saint
cyriens de participer à la vie
municipale ce qui n'était pas forcément
toujours le cas et j'en suis ravi ça
veut peut-être dire qu'on aura plus
d'électeurs plus de participation à
l'élection municipale en 2020 lydie du
long pont tête de liste de
saint-cyr-l'ecole en commun actuellement
animatrice de communauté
elle s'est lancée dans le mouvement
local citoyen et participatif investi
dans la vie associative locale
elle est devenue éducatrice à
l'environnement avant de devenir tête de
liste
si je me suis investi dans ce mouvement
c'est parce que je pense que il est très
important d'agir maintenant et qu'on ne
peut pas se permettre d'attendre encore
six ans pour être vraiment au contact
proche des habitants et savoir ce qui
les intéresse ce qu'ils ont envie de
faire pour l'heure pour leur ville